hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to voidtrain i just had
to play it again it's just oh my god
oh my god
um
um um um um um
i legitimately did not know that that
was there when i started this oh
no
all right you could you come here you
come here you yeah you come here you
you're not so tough now that i got
pistol better than a spear or nothing
like that no
no no no no no get get get get
there are head shots in this so my train
is sustained damage
yeah the damage is a bit of a problem
good gilly
come here you come here you come here
come on let me get those head shots
in the eyeballs
where you come here you yeah you won i
know you're low on health though i i bet
you got goodies too
there you are yeah that's what i thought
that's what i thought and that's what i
thought just in case
just in case
no no no
why did you do that to me
why
oh you
i knew that it would have a thing i knew
that it would have a thing the other
thing had a thing
god damn it
all right break blocked speed up oh it
had a thing do you have things
what do you got what is that
meat
i love meat all right so now that we're
getting back into this we're gonna try
to be a little better we killed our
first big whatever
i thought i saw another one no
no
no oh you're wily
you're wily aren't ya
okay so is this just gonna be a constant
thing a new deluge of uh people coming
after me is that what i'm gonna have to
endure
i bet it is i bet it is all right
whatever can i go through this at like a
just to crawl i don't want to go fast
you know i just want the slowest creep
just like tiny okay this is better this
is better i don't know why anyone would
want to go through this fast unless
you're trying to run away from something
then maybe
okay but let's see yes this is why so i
can actually see what's coming up and i
can get what i need i still feel like
i'm going too fast
maybe there's like a minimum speed that
you can actually crawl through all right
but now that i have that
i'm going to make more metal
because it's never enough and then
i see that metal shining so the metal is
very shiny
oh yes oh yes
maybe it's given me more now that i'm
getting later in the game oh missed that
i wonder if there's a point where i'll
get like an actual train engine here you
know what i mean
and i'll be just be freaking booking it
and i'll just have magnets sucking up
everything around me
that'd be nice okay seems like my metal
is done
let's see what this thing has
work bench okay gear come in handy bolt
spring okay let's just make one of each
and see what happens transmission what
is the turn oh switch direction oh i can
back up i forgot about that
huh well that would be handy if i see
something behind me that i really wanted
which i have in the past and i haven't
been able to get not enough space okay
um i might need another chest i think
you're going to be
a wood chest and you're going to be
oh needs
you need two iron bars to make you i
forgot about that what is that
what is that
what is that you can shoot an obstacle
by aiming at the explosive fruit and
it's by but what is it
and before i kill it i just want to see
what it is get out of the way
look out
hold on
all right well that hurt
maybe oh okay this is starting to get
goopy
and i never like when things get goopy
so you uh
stop being so goddamn goopy okay
kablam blim
it's very goopy
i'm moving again
i know you don't
wait what did you drop what'd you drop
stop stop stop stop nope god damn it
stop
stop stop stop
no just me i thought it dropped a thing
again
i'm never gonna get that thing whatever
it was it looked like a rolled up like
maybe a blueprint of some kind maybe it
would save me some research you know
what i mean
i know i need platform technology phase
four i know that's my objective but i'm
not doing it right now not seeing a lot
of stuff
at least not the good stuff anyway now
here's the good stuff so what do we need
to research we need
a lab ooh that is some stuff
that's so much stuff
there's got to be a better way
there's got to be a better way
thankfully copper only takes one medal
which is nice
meadow
go ahead and make more copper now i need
10 michaels
which i have here
okay i see this metal over here
[Music]
oh i see you
bam boom ah come on you you think you're
good you're not
there we oh there there there there
there goddamn give give oh am i out of
space no no no no no not like
i can go backwards i can go backwards i
can go backwards wait stop hold on wait
wait
backwards
oh my god
i hate this i hate everything about this
okay back up faster please
scooch a little quicker
scooch and hit the brakes i love that
let's see if i'm making um
copper pipe did i make copper pipe and
let's see
meant a good tube or whatever don't
matter all right you you you
what are leather
ah
leather interesting okay all right now
we can go forward
i'm really running out of space and
these these things do not hold anything
at all but now that i have metal i can
do a blueprint oh i need bolts so i need
one more bolt i know i have two
but then i need more metal anyway oh
yeah yeah
never enough never enough they really do
have me chasing materials
like every single opportunity is getting
materials or else i have nothing
which is fine it keeps it engaged i
don't mind i'm not complaining not a big
whiner
i'm a bit of a whiner okay let's pause
for a second pause right here
because now i think i have enough oh i
need the bolts right right right right
so i actually have to grab wait didn't i
make
can i make the bolt
no i did not so i now actually have the
bolts and i have leather
and i have this which i could just eat
right now
eat oh man i'm not doing good dirty ice
hues
i'm sure that at some point that'll come
back to haunt me but for now i can choke
it down lab
lab i love lab we love lab and how much
does lab take to build
i'm gonna guess an ungodly amount lab
okay two more bolts of course the thing
that needed to research it is the thing
that needs to build it love that about
that
two more bolts all right now that i have
two of these
i have one of these is that enough to
build a lab
no wire got it just the one ah okay uh
let's be copper make oh my goodness okay
and with this
i now have enough to build a lab which i
don't even think is my objective right
now
lab
lab
bam i have a lab i wish it was more
fanfare when i build things takes enough
research to do it
lab unstable chemical ingredient needed
to make create useful items and
substances
great
build one of those put some fuel in this
bad boy get it going i don't know what
this is for
but i'm gonna guess that's helpful i
guess i gotta start picking up chemicals
again
i don't like the sound of that
whatever that was
what was that oh no here we go
we're coming up on the pit stop
whoa
what the hell i want to shoot you
i have a bad feeling what will happen if
i shoot you oh my god it's a void whale
that is definitively avoid whale i've
heard of void whale in so many different
like universes like fictional universes
but that is a freaking void whale i do
not feel comfortable going into the
distance where the void whale is not
that i think it's gonna get me i think
it's probably a peaceful void whale but
just in case ooh
satisfy hunger but can experience health
issues afterwards
yeah eating strange creatures from the
beyond probably not the best thing i
could do for myself very impressive
we're all very impressed
i mean i am actually very impressed a
lot of gravitas a lot of importance ah
metal god damn it go go go
nice
okay where am i sitting i've got six
metal four copper one of these weird
unstable things and then i still need to
research platform technology which i
don't know where that oh i'm still in
phase three oh i'm still an [ __ ]
where do i get that gold thing what is
that
what is that
what what is any of that what other i've
never seen these things
oh hey
okay so it's same as before it's just
random station i'm not even in stage
four yet
i'm not even done with stage three okay
moderately concerning
there's fat oh i needed to kill things
oh why didn't you tell me sooner
i would have been murdering up a storm i
mean it says it cause health issues but
you know
i'm healthy i'm healthy enough okay i
think that was pretty much everything
i don't think there was anything else in
here that i could have gotten or could
have missed i'm gonna pretend like that
thing in the distance is not real i'm
not gonna look at it i fell off
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
get me back get me back
i didn't realize i could just jump off
over here but maybe that means i could
climb up here
ooh interesting
oh fascinating oh this is weird
oh this is very weird oh that's very
weird
interesting
there's definitely some glitch climbing
you could do in this game there's
definitely some exploits you could
you could find
but for now i'll leave it at that i'm
not going to explore too deeply about it
because i have to get to work i have a
lot of things that i need to do
like researching this with my fat that i
have now oh yeah that's what i'm talking
about i need more fat i just gotta kill
things man i gotta murder
i gotta murder so much all right let's
keep mosing
much faster than i thought it'd be
much speedier
all right
is there gonna be another one of those
void sharks coming after me actually
let's hit the brakes hit the brakes real
quick
okay
i don't see anything coming after me so
i think i'm gonna be okay
but just for now what do i have what do
i need i need to get more animal fat
there's a workbench here with stuff that
is important i will eventually need to
get those did i get any more things that
i could build
i don't think so
i do need to get more platforms because
i'm quickly running out of space here
all right let's just keep moving
oh
oh i thought i heard something
well i did i did hear something god damn
it okay you [ __ ] you want to go you
want to tussle with the muscle
all right i'm stopping
come here you
try me i missed every shot they're all
warning shots
look at my incredible aim you're not so
tough
you're not so scary
i can't it's hard to tell what the
bullet arc actually is
there we go
[ __ ]
i'm on you [ __ ] where's your health bar
where are you at what's your health at
oh boy here we go okay okay
come at me
come on get closer i don't want to lose
what you got
i am going to shoot you guys in case you
give me fat
whoa whoa whoa whoa that was fast okay
die yes
yes
give me your meat and your leather
give me everything
you are horrifying i do not like the
look of you oh
bang
get out of here so if i shoot these guys
they give me things
i bet if i kill a void wheel i get so
much fat out of it all right let's go
now that i've properly disposed with
everyone here
yeah shockingly i've actually gotten
ahead of the
whoo
another one
what was that
what was that
another one
what does that sound
sounds big
don't like the fog
i don't like it
no i don't like it and what is the sound
why do i hear it
get out of here
there we go fat fat fat
yes yes
there we go that's exactly what i needed
now i can research yes okay research no
no no no i needed the uh i need to
actually make it this create
yes
what is that sound
what is that sound okay
what is it
oh
i don't like it
don't like it i don't like it
i don't like it i do not like it
all right so that's been researched
that's probably fun okay so now we're in
phase four right platform okay
okay okay so two springs
two bolts i have one one spring i know
that and then whatever the hell the
looks like maybe a ball bearing or
something like that where do i build
that ah
it is a bearing okay but i need more fat
which means that i need to kill again
hey fat
well that's convenient give me some of
that let's make a bearing
we might have needed two i'm not 100
sure and i guarantee that i'm gonna need
all the stuff that i just spent to
research it again
because that's how it works here i made
two pieces of fat come closer you
beauties
still don't like the groaning
damn it
missed but that might be enough that was
another fat
make another one of these make another
bearing
and then i'll just have to make even
more
another bearing bam
man the amount of stuff to make is
pretty intense
and
bang bang bang bang bang bang miss miss
miss miss where you going are you going
buddy
oh nailed that one okay cool tutorial
preparing there's many interesting
things ahead of you
including expanding your train you need
to be prepared so gather resources
craft parts and fully develop yourself
yeah i
been working on it that's what i've been
doing oh a kitchen
and bang oh [ __ ] okay come on i'm gonna
get you i'm gonna get you you're old dad
you're dead you're dead you're dead
you're dead you're dead i shot the same
one twice
that's how dangerous i am
you be prepared
you better watch out
bang a bang
bang oh bang i feel like this there we
go that's fat give me that murder murder
murder
man i'm really bad at the whole
murdering thing
which i guess is not the worst thing to
be able to say about yourself
i probably shouldn't look into that too
much
all right now i can build
another
nothing i researched nothing i'm just
surrounded by corpses
bang uh neither of them gave anything
okay i think i've thinned the herds
pretty much as much as i can thin them
so let's go ahead and make um
resin
okay i'll make resin i don't know what
resin's for but i can make it i never
liked them from the beginning so i don't
feel bad i'm sorry i feel kind of bad
bang i feel bad oh i feel so terrible so
i'm doing okay i need to research
kitchen eventually
unless there was a way to build a
platform already do i have that
capability i don't think i do i don't
know i don't know i need more chemicals
i'm not getting enough of those
there we go
ugh
still hear you i don't know what that's
about
what is oh my god no
no is that just a void well please tell
me that's just a void whale
oh please tell me it's just a void whale
oh i really hope that's just a void
whale
i really want that to be just a void
well but i have a funny feeling it's not
good thing it doesn't see me over here
because that would be terrifying so i
researched that
i don't have anything
uh um oh
i wait no i i should be able to research
that what do i did i know i don't have
any organics
oh my god i have not been picking up
organics in so long
hey uh
oh no it's ice where oh man i'm out of
organics that is bizarre
also i feel like i'm going a bit faster
than i usually would be going
organics here we go and then that
chemical i have i could definitely
research that research
this definitely
the sterilizer which is probably for
bandages and whatever [ __ ] like that
you know unimportant crap oh what's with
the husks no thank you
there we go
oh do not like that
it's all indicative of something
terrible going on here i don't know how
all these pieces of metal got ruined but
i have a funny feeling they might
actually be train pieces from previous
trains that have tried to foolishly go
through the void
unlike me i'm definitely gonna survive
okay now that i have that i need to
actually get a sterilizer
so it's probably in the lab yeah so
chemical
and organics which again i do not have
oh there it is and here i was foolishly
eating the organics like an idiot and
that'll get me to phase five that was a
lot easier than phase four was i'll say
that keep moving forward is my only
progression it says well all right keep
moving forward i shall oh i can burn fat
ooh i won't do that until i absolutely
know that i can sacrifice some fat to do
that but i bet it's much more efficient
than wood okay oh
taming the rough flemo
i don't want to tame the raw flemo
i really don't want to do that oh hammer
i bet that's how
wait no no it's not no it's not how do i
do it there's probably something else
it's going to give me
probably something else is going to give
me
eventually
i imagine
maybe
oh god give me back consumables
ooh
bandu's but i don't need that too much
right now
i seem to be relatively okay i'm just
gonna go ahead and build one of each of
these again
just because i can
okay i bet it i bet in this next one i'm
gonna get something to expand my train
because i feel like i should have
something
i took a lot of stops in that last one
which definitely probably threw off my
progression but i felt like i had to to
get a better handle of exactly what i
was doing and where i was
and also i need to set up a better
system to be able to get food i know i
have i know i researched the kitchen
so i know i have that kit kit catching
catching okay i just need two of the
two of these things
okay this is different
this is definitely different all right
i'll come back for you
this is definitely different but doesn't
matter though is the question
oh it's different all right
hello
oh yeah oh yeah
oh no never mind
i thought but i thought wrong ah i
thought that was gonna be like another
story place
oh
come on
all right if that is it then that's it
okay so anyway i'm all out of time for
this episode but i did get what i need
to build a kitchen and eventually i'll
figure out how to build another train
i'm sure the the solution is is right
there and it's right here in front of me
but for some reason i can't
i tried to do the wooden floor but that
don't work because it's just here and
then
yeah you know i'll figure it out i'll
get it but i love this this is fantastic
if you want to get this game for
yourself it's available through the link
in the description below use my creator
code uh to get it on the epic game store
and just thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
this and uh don't give me any tips or
tricks i don't want them i have them
already in my head thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you